en su fondo de pantalla su gran ídola
karine de 17 años sueña con seguir los
pasos de Marta una leyenda del fútbol en
Brasil
he tenido este sueño desde que era
pequeña porque he jugado desde entonces
este sueño me acompaña y creo que podré
hacerlo hasta entonces es un proceso y
lo respetaré Tengo este sueño de ser
futbolista
los rincones de su casa ubicada en un
complejo de fabilas en Río de Janeiro
delatan su afición al deporte una que
comparte con su madre que no pudo
hacerlo su profesión debido a las
enormes brechas que recaen sobre el
fútbol femenino el fútbol representa a
todos sufrimos prejuicios porque siempre
dicen que el fútbol no es para mujeres
es para hombres como carines son muchas
las jóvenes que se han acercado al
fútbol en las favelas de Brasil un
deporte que según los organizadores del
proyecto cara a cara ha servido para
alejar a las menores de edad de
diferentes tipos de violencia
la posibilidad de hacer cosas malas
especialmente en la comunidad de la
Favela Es abrumadora somos una
oportunidad más para que hagan el bien
en la comunidad que no se fijen solo en
las cosas malas sino que tengan un
camino correcto
el proyecto promueve torneos como la
Favela cop y Espera que de ahí surjan
las nuevas generaciones que releven a la
selección que en pocos días representará
a Brasil en el mundial de Australia y
Nueva Zelanda